all right boys it's time for another
experiment today we're going to see if
my fully upgraded mimic tier summon can
defeat merget the fel omen this fight
has been giving so many people an
absolute wall of difficulty to get
through
and i just want to see if my summon can
beat him man i have no idea no clue if
my summon can beat this guy
a mimic had no problem beating the tree
sentinel but this guy's on another level
yeah i think my mimic's about to
extinguish your flame buddy all right
let's see if i can get some space to get
it off because he throws stuff at you oh
god he's already coming
all right i'm staying completely out of
the fight i want nothing to do with this
all right i'm gonna see if i can just
sit and watch
oh my god my summons going off dude wow
merget doesn't even do that much damage
to him dude
this is still so overpowered he's got
him to have health already are you
serious i am actually so surprised at
how well this is going like he is
literally me like my summon is actually
as strong as me this is so overpowered
okay now he's getting his ass kicked and
i think he's gonna get knocked off the
map
why is he just not doing anything there
you go no don't fall don't fall
he's gonna fall off the map
no
he's doing he applied a bleed damage run
mimic
run
get away from the side and don't hit me
this is intense this is getting really
close uh to me i'm a little scared and
he did it oh my god i can't believe he
did it yeah
yep yep the mimic is absolutely
overpowered well guys i didn't have to
do anything again and i got all the
runes from that fight didn't have to do
a thing this is great i think my mimic
could potentially beat the entire game
at this point because merget is no joke
of a boss like people are struggling on
this guy and are actually quitting this
game because of this boss so it just
goes to show you that you get pretty
damn strong in this game once you keep
going alright boys that's pretty much it
let me know which boss you'd like to see
the mimic fight next see in the next
video guys have a good one